[Music]
so
good morning and welcome to the face of
steel here in the magna science
adventure center in the former temple
bro steel works in rotherham we're here
for big ideas live a new format for sky
news that we hope will help us to
explore big issues big themes big ideas
across the agenda for the uk today on
inking live we're kicking off our
coverage exploring the challenges facing
the economy as we come out of the
pandemic is boris johnson's promise of a
high wage high skills economy
deliverable and what would it mean for
business and are the problems that we're
seeing in the country's supply chains a
symptom of short-term worker shortages
or are we in for a longer ride i'll be
discussing that with a panel taken from
across british business and i'll be
introducing them in a moment i'd also
like to invite you to ask questions or
comments during our day using the
hashtag big ideas live
but first a feature of big ideas live
will be our sky news experts later we'll
hear from our economics and data editor
ed conway and my colleagues samantha
washington and trevor phillips but first
our business correspondent helen anne
smith is here to set the scene for our
discussion helen ann
thanks ian good morning everyone so
what's happened in the jobs market over
the last 18 months is perhaps one of the
greatest curiosities of this crisis
normally at times of recession we see
unemployment spiking we see vacancies
falling right down although unemployment
has been kept relatively in check
vacancies have actually behaved in
entirely the opposite way to what we
might have expected just this morning we
heard vacancies in september up record
highs again over 1.1 million and
although that might seem like good news
on the surface for workers the reality
might be a bit more nuanced and there's
big challenges for business about how to
realign to the new reality post pandemic
so first of all have a look at this what
we're plotting here is some of the the
key sectors that are driving that big
growth in vacancies up there at the top
transport and logistics we've heard so
much about it haven't we up 300 job
adverts there on what they were pre
pandemic but problems in other sectors
too manufacturing construction even
travel and tourism surprising perhaps
given the problems that that sector has
faced uh however that's not the case uh
in all sectors across the economy have a
look at this we've plotted here is some
sectors where job vacancies are actually
down on what they were before the
pandemic some of this might not be that
surprising for example sales we know
retail
has had some problems but some sectors
here are a little bit surprising jobs
down in energy jobs down in legal
graduate jobs down as well and what's
essentially showing us is that there's a
realignment going to be happening in the
economy we know for example don't we
that there can be fewer jobs in places
for example like city centre sandwich
shops more jobs in places like
warehouses it may be a bit too soon to
see some of these things really playing
out in the data but some of the early
signs are certainly interesting now the
question for many of us is not just
where are the jobs but actually where
are the workers to fill all of these
vacancies and it's quite interesting
they might not necessarily always be in
the right places so what we've done here
is charting the number of unemployed and
furloughed people as of july against the
number of uh
regions of the country so essentially
the higher up they are on this graph the
more unemployed and furloughed people
there were as of july the further along
they are uh the greater growth in
vacancies that those sectors have seen
what this essentially shows there's
different problems in different regions
london for example right up there at the
top absolutely the worst place to be in
the country right now if you're a worker
by far the highest number of people
potentially looking for work the fewest
vacancies over at the other side
different problems the northeast at the
largest number of vacancies there
yorkshire and the humber where we are
today higher vacancies and comparatively
fewer people looking for those jobs
so not only might the workers not be in
the right places but they might not also
be at the right skill level have a look
at this there is a slight correlation
between the number of vacancies in
certain sectors and the average earnings
in those sectors so over at this side
hospitality many more vacancies lower
pay on average over there on the other
end finance worth saying anecdotally
transport up there the big vacancies
driver anecdotally we do know that some
of the jobs that do exist are in those
lower paying driving jobs as opposed to
the managerial jobs as well and look as
we go forward over the coming years and
the coming decades there will be other
new challenges for businesses as well i
want to leave you with this one of the
challenges we may all face is automation
what this essentially shows is that
there is a direct correlation uh
anecdotally between uh how likely a
sector was to furlough its workers in
the recent crisis and how at risk that
sector might be from automation so look
up here at the top food and tourism
retail construction to a degree as well
highly likely to have furloughed their
workers during this crisis much more at
risk of automation over here on the
opposite end media scientific i.t of
course it won't go unnoticed that these
tend to be the higher paying careers as
well potentially slightly lower paying
over there so we big questions for
businesses not just about how these
factors all collide are we creating more
vulnerable group of workers going
forward but crucially also how business
is going to rise to this challenge and
we'll be able to find the workers that
are needed thank you ian thanks helen
time now to introduce you to my panel of
experts on my far right is lord
billamoria the chairman of cobra founder
of furcobra and also president of the
cbi on my immediate right alvina malek
she's chief executive and co-founder of
one million mentors which pairs young
people with mentors in industry on my
immediate left is carl annis he's chief
executive of siemens here in the uk and
also ceo of siemens smart infrastructure
and on my far left is clive chesser he's
chief executive of punch pubs and co and
we also have expertise in our audience
today from the regional business
community from local business owners and
hopefully one or two business leaders of
the future now before we get on to our
panel discussion we're going to touch on
a very live piece of news something
that's happened just around the corner
from here during the last 24 hours which
is that
the liberty still business has just been
told it's receiving a 50 million pounds
cash injection from its owner and i'm
very pleased to say we have chris
williamson in the audience he's branch
secretary of the community trade union
at liberty steel's rotherham plant chris
welcome to you you must be absolutely
delighted fantastic news uh it's great
relief
we've it's been arrowing for the last
few months but
it's
a great
piece of mind to to get that
funding in place
i mean i mean obviously still production
is an energy intensive business
energy bills the wholesale level and of
the retail level are going through the
roof right now do you worry that that
money is going to be consumed fairly
rapidly
if bolus is true to his word with his
rhetoric this morning hopefully we'll
get some movement
it is a deep concern we've had concerns
around energy for the last 30 years
around leveling up with the rest of
europe
but obviously this crisis has escalated
all right
chris great pleasure to have you here
with us today thanks very much for
joining us
on we go then and uh lord billy mora i'm
going to start with you we heard from
boris johnson last week he clearly wants
to turn the uk into a high-wage economy
but it seems to me i mean economic
orthodoxy is that high wages follow an
improvement in productivity boris
johnson it feels like he's trying to put
the car before the horse
we all want a high
wage
high skills
high investment
and high productivity
so you can say you want high wages but
unless you have all the other things
it's going to lead to inflation
so we've got to take this opportunity
now
we all want those higher wages but
invest in skills now is the time those
graphs that we've just seen
the disintermediation that's going to
take place in the future regardless of
the pandemic regardless of the crisis
we're facing now that's staring us in
the face
so the cbi we've calculated over the
next decade
businesses will have to invest 130
billion pounds in re-skilling
so what the government's got to do is
right now things like the kickstart
scheme fantastic scheme to get young
people 16 to 24 year olds into work we
said please extend that beyond december
they've listened they're going to extend
it
things like the lifelong learning
account what a great initiative so
people at any age in their lives have
access to money to be able to retrain
the apprenticeship levy
good idea not working it needs to be far
more flexible so if you do all those
things you can reskill and our
universities the best in the world along
with america i'm proud to be chancellor
of the university of birmingham top 100
university in the world along with
siemens with carl and his team we've a
brand new ai enabled campus in dubai
state of the art 5000 students
that's global britain in action so we
can do it we're proving it let's invest
in it once you have that investment once
you have the skills
then you get the high wages and you have
the productivity then you get growth
that growth delivers jobs the jobs pay
the taxes the taxes pay for the public
services and pay down the debt the 400
billion
pounds that we're so grateful is
business the government has given that's
why unemployment the figures that have
come out today
at only four and a half percent before
the pandemic were the lowest in the
seventies three and a half percent
people were expecting unemployment to go
up to ten percent if you remember off
the financial crisis
unemployment went up to over nine
percent and we
saved that now thanks to the government
help including the furlough scheme now
it's a very fragile recovery and this is
where government mustn't give up now
this is where government's going to work
with business to really support this
fragile recovery so we can have that
growth okay well kyle obviously you
invest an awful lot in skills and in uh
equipping the workforce for the modern
economy
to what extent was that work blown off
course by the pandemic
so actually we were we were quite lucky
in that much of what we do was for
supporting national infrastructure
keeping the trains running uh keeping
the energy systems up and running
keeping medical equipment running so
actually we we were able to employ
pretty much throughout many people
continuing to do what they were doing at
the at the face of work
and and a lot of our office people you
know adopted uh adopted technology and
were able to work from home so so i
think
we
we were able to survive that skill topic
if i just pick up on on the other topic
that karen completely agree with all of
that
and uh one of the ways you address
productivity is uh uh is by deploying
technology now it was really interesting
listening to uh it was helena as in her
introduction she talks about risk of
automation and actually that for me
speaks volumes right there is no risk
from alteration there is a risk from not
automating because if we don't others
will i think about the global britain is
that means we're on a global stage we
have to be competitive globally and i
truly believe if we don't adopt uh
automation new technologies at all in
all industrial areas then we will be
missing one of the biggest levers to
drive that productivity up that's just
the reality it is quite a terrifying
idea though i mean it's a lot of people
isn't it the thought that they may lose
their job to ai to automation i mean how
how do you sell that to a skeptical
public um well
i think as
uh clive was saying you know automation
is reality and we need to embrace it um
and i think there is a huge amount to do
in terms of investing in skills one of
the things lord berna moria that we need
to do alongside all of the things that
you've outlined is actually invest in
our young people
and do it differently because if we keep
doing what we're doing we're going to
get the same result we're going to have
a disconnect that we have in the labor
market right now
what we do at one million mentors is we
provide
opportunities for business to connect
with local young people the talent the
abundance of talent that does exist in
our communities and we need to really
escalate that and really um scale that
up and put funding into those
connections
early on if we can get to young people
early on
uh if we can introduce them to the world
of the work world of work if we can
expose them to
opportunities guide them support them
pre-gcse
to automated jobs to data you know
gathering be comfortable with technology
they are comfortable with digital tools
by the way young people aren't fearful
of automation but what they're fearful
of is not having the opportunities to go
into jobs which are highly skilled and
they're not prepared for that
whose role is that though is that the
role of local businesses or should the
schools be playing a greater role in
that i mean do you think the schools are
doing enough right now on that front
good point and i i think schools are
doing brilliantly by the way um i do
sort of resist the narrative that we
pedal that is all on schools to do um
everything you know look after young
people's well-being educate them get
them jobs ready what we need is a really
um
scalable effort a collective effort like
we've never seen in the uk before which
is bringing business into schools and
supporting young people
alongside education by the way not as
part of the education alongside a
parallel
system whereby we are getting young
people job ready alongside being
educated and the way we think that can
be done is through personalized
one-to-one support businesses actively
engaging and supporting young people
through mentoring coaching and so forth
okay clive i'm conscious we haven't let
you have a chance to speak yet but
before we do just want to go back to
chris in the audience if you could share
some of your experiences in terms of
training and skilling what's it what's
it like at liberty uh it's basically on
the job training
there's obviously we have
apprenticeships for
engineering side of things but
the production side is more on the job
training and
it is a
it's a good level and
we
thought it
made to ensure that the competent before
we put him obviously into such a
dangerous environment of course
thank you well clive obviously
your business employs an awful lot of
young people
when they join you
are they fit for the world of work i
remember one of this country's
best-known chief executives more than a
decade ago massive employer better not
say who it was
and i remember him saying to me when we
get people out of school or college the
first thing we have to do is teach them
how to read and write and count because
a lot of them can't do it properly
are things better than that that was a
decade ago i was told that
yeah things that things are definitely
better than that i mean pub pubs so we
run
a punch pubs and co we run thirteen 300
community pubs right across the uk so
from the isle of skye to the isle of
silly actually
and so our pubs provide a great entry
point for young people into the world of
work
and it's it's it's about
personality as much as about technical
skills uh and our publicans do a
fantastic job i think at developing
people into the world of work as an
industry we need to do better at making
sure that people see it as a career
opportunity and a longer term career
opportunity as opposed to a sort of
transient first job
but uh you know we we see people coming
to our industry all the time from a very
young age and they can rise as stars and
be managing their own businesses
actually within two or three years it's
quite unusual so you know it's important
for us uh i think to uh to make sure
that uh you know we we continue to be
able to provide those opportunities uh
and at the minute you know things are
obviously very difficult we've got pubs
that are struggling to find uh find the
staff that we need and if we're
struggling to find them then i think
everybody must be really key point
you've touched on their labor shortages
right now i mean obviously the
hospitality industry had a terrible time
during the the pandemic
lots of businesses went under
where do you go from here are you seeing
signs of optimism now despite these
labor shortages
yeah it's really it's really
complicated actually i mean it's
confusing and it's not it's not a
consistent picture across the country so
there are you know they're very
different stories actually so pubs down
in the southwestern sort of domestic
tourism land have had you know
phenomenal trade through the summer but
there are a number of businesses that
have had a really much slower recovery
and a much tougher time
generally speaking i think we're you
know we're quite optimistic about the
rebound that we've seen in consumer
demand
the challenge is in satisfying that
demand and the complexity of delivering
um through the supply chain through
labor and it's very frustrating actually
that you know in some areas you know
we're not able to keep up with that and
that's a very unusual place for us to be
so
fragile complicated but actually the
underlying position i think is one of
optimism and you know we've seen the
love of people coming back to
hospitality and community pubs in
particular being really strong so that
we know that in the long term if we can
get all the pieces right along the way
actually i think the long term rebound
can look strong
but obviously we've got inflation coming
through the pipeline are you going to be
able to absorb is that hits going to be
on your margins are you going to be able
to pass that on to customers
well a huge amount of costs are being
absorbed right now uh in increasingly
day by day uh that's getting more
difficult um and nobody wants to see
prices just being passed on to customers
uh there's you know clearly uh you know
this price elasticity and and we've got
to deliver great value and quality
to our to our guests in our pubs so
the truth is that costs are being
absorbed and margins are getting
squeezed um and we need to continue to
get the support that we've had from
government through the through the
coveted pandemic beyond the current uh
measures that are in place in the longer
term and to have a real transition plan
you know i thought that i thought that
the tone of the um
of the the the conference last week in
the prime minister's speech felt quite
celebratory as if covert is now in the
rearview mirror and it's been gone
that's not how it feels um kate nicholls
who runs uk hospitality i think said uh
that the the the industry has got some
symptoms of long covid that's quite a
good analogy because fundamentally we're
back up and running we're out of
hospital we're healthy we're open but
we've still got some symptoms that are
very real
and we need the support from the
government for our sector in particular
extending the vat cut is really
important because that does help to
prevent price increases being passed
straight through to the consumer
but also help with
with
beer duty in particular for the
hospitality sector and the on trade
sector and then the business rates
reform which is promised
but we've got a long way until that
comes in we've got some support in place
now until march next year and that needs
to be extended as well because that is a
very significant cost for businesses
like ours that are bricks and mortar on
the high street in towns across the
country so we need a strong transition
plan from the government to enable us to
get through these symptoms of long
covert and then i think the future can
look can look bright
obviously low pay is a real issue
throughout the economy the prime
minister's uh made it very clear it's on
his agenda and we have a question to
that end from tiffany jackson
in the audience tiffany would you like
to
make yourself
known to us
my question is how important is it for
young people to have a voice in the
dialogue around the future of work and
learning and how can businesses help
facilitate and support this
thanks tiffany uh for those did you
catch that the question was how
important is it for young people to have
a voice in the dialogue around the
future of work i think yeah you're very
well placed
brilliant
absolutely integral for young people to
be part of that dialogue what we know is
we have
one of the most diverse most educated
labor coming through young people coming
through into the economy and they're
very clear about what they want they're
very clear you know they are
mobile they're resilient they're values
driven they want businesses that are
supporting their well-being they want
ethical leadership they want um you know
inclusive
ideal
um
they want to work
in places where they have good wages
where there is career progression and
where there are good conditions you know
and i think they have to be part of the
solution but for me the onus really is
on
the employers um you know to be able to
change their culture change their
practices change their uh recruitment
and hiring practices in order to attract
this phenomenal talent that is in the uk
karen did you want to jump in yes and
it's such an important point because if
you think about this crisis
lots of us we've all suffered
but young people have suffered so much
whether it's missing out on school
whether it's missing out on university
it's been really really difficult
and i think we've got to do everything
we can to support young people and as
alvina said that what matters all the
surveys show the two things that are
more important to young people
than other things one they passionately
care about climate change sustainability
diverse biodiversity the environment
really matters the next thing is
diversity and inclusion it really
matters i'm the first ethnic minority
cbi president in its history
and i've launched an initiative called
change the race ratio
to champion ethnic minority
participation across all business and
lots of big companies have signed up to
it microsoft ey aviva siemens everyone's
it's it's a fantastic initiative that's
the sort of thing we've got to do and
the other thing is
at schools
we've got to get businesses into schools
if
survey after survey is shown if you if
if children are exposed to business
through visits from business leaders
into schools they are so much more
likely to be employable
secondly field visits if children go and
visit businesses visit factories it has
a huge impact on i can still remember my
field visits from 11 years old when i
went to a pencil factory
it has a big impact so i think we've got
to put young people make a very
important priority all right carl i'm
going to come to you in a second but we
have a question on the related uh issue
here from bob jeffrey who's in the
audience bob if you'd like to uh there
he is
hi i'm bob jeffrey i'm the uh president
of sheffield tuc the local trades
council or the neighbouring trades
council
and given the lack of effective
employment protections here in the uk we
relatively come near the bottom of the
league of oecd countries for for
employment protection how are how
important are trade unions in terms of
driving up the quality of jobs
thanks bob who wants to take that how
important are trade unions in driving
the quality of jobs
uh well i'll have a hell of a crack at
it um um i would say uh that listen
the the any mechanism that gives the
voice of the employee to
the senior levels of the organization
has to be has to be an important element
uh in siemens we have parts of our
organization where they are uh trade
unions are recognized in others where
where they're not uh and and actually
it's horses for courses so i don't think
it's the only route for communication
back to alvina's point and then the
question earlier actually i find the
interaction within with the employees
individually on uh far more uh far more
useful uh than perhaps you know uh uh
conglomerated responses so so i would
say yeah we need to listen to our
employees i mean we are listening to our
employees uh and and on that topic of of
training and the voice of individuals
i'm i'm
lucky enough to have two children a 16
year old daughter and a 19 year old son
who have lived their all levels and a
levels through the pandemic and
and actually you know that's why i agree
that it is a group of people who have
hugely suffered actually we've embraced
technology we've been doing uh work
experience uh remotely and actually
there's quite an interesting challenge
for us as an engineering organisation we
often find it difficult to get to ethnic
minorities to get to agenda balance
correctly actually in our our um
online workplace experience uh we ended
up having 50 female
attendees and more than 50 in black and
minor
minority ethnics so actually those new
ways of engaging with people have also
been something that we're going to
continue to doing post-pandemic so
there's lots of pain in the pandemic but
there's also lots of things we've
learned that have been useful and we
should be you know careful not to throw
the baby out with the bath water and
make sure we embrace and keep embracing
those new ways of of engaging
karen made the point about getting
schools into business
how have you been able to market
engineering and science careers as sexy
to school kids
that's a trick isn't it uh although i i
have to say i'm you know what we might
talk about uh karen mentioned about
decarbonization the biggest global
challenge for the world uh and who's
going to fix it right probably an
engineer and a scientist are going to be
at the heart of it that makes that's
pretty sexy so we we were involved uh in
in
in the ventilator challenge so we were
involved in a number of of other
engineering organizations when the call
came that there was a concern we weren't
going to have enough ventilators we were
making 20 a week we needed to make 2 000
a week
and within the space of four weeks we
had uh we'd created a production line
we'd use digital technology to do it
we'd used uh the knowledge of of the
experts we'd taken management and left
management to them at the door to to
avoid egos and actually we we found a
solution and it was brilliant and you
know again i look unfortunately i've not
been able to convince either of my
children to go into engineering but
that's because i'm a rugby salesman
and however that that i think they see
now starting to see now the value of
science and engineering
but of course we need to keep on about
it it's easily forgotten and and yes we
have them uh uh young young people
coming into our organization we also
have a lot of our employees who are
engaged with with young people i sit on
the engineering uk uh uh board which is
a group of businesses uh supporting key
stage two and three so very early on in
getting over this idea that that an
engineer is somebody who comes home with
with grit under the fingernails now i do
that sometimes because i like uh
tinkering in my garage but actually
generally there's lots more that we can
do and actually if we're really at the
cornerstone of fixing the the the future
of the planet i think that's quite a
sexy place to be
is it time that we started to
abandon this target of half the
country's college leavers going to
university and push more people into
apprenticeships
um only if the apprenticeships work
um and i think there's a lot more work
we need to do with apprenticeships but
there are lots of different
opportunities and i think picking up
what carl was saying
young people are
i mean they have had as you said law
bill mori they have been
disproportionately affected by the
pandemic the education disruption the
uncertainty around gcse and a levels my
children went through the same
experience and it was as hard for them
as it was for as a parent but young
people now as the lock down eases are
feeling a lot more positive which is
really interesting you know they're
beginning to socialize a bit more but
they're also being able to pick up
opportunities that they wouldn't have
had pre-pandemic so the young people
that we work with over three thousand um
some of them are now applying for roles
because of remote working uh they live
in the north but they're applying for
roles in the south and i think that's
fantastic and i think that's really
positive uh in terms of geographical
barriers not being as
important as they were pre-pandemic and
we need to keep that going i think young
people
are beginning to look at opportunities
beyond university and i do think it is
important that they do that because we
know what the skills shortage is we know
what future jobs looks like and
therefore it's incumbent on all of us
here in this room and across the country
to identify and support young people
from an early age pre-gcse
to
find the right career path for them
which doesn't mean university for some
are you recognizing that clive totally
totally come to hospitality um we're we
need you we want you and and it's a
great a great career path for young
people and then i guess my request to
the government in terms of working with
us to help unlock some of the uh some of
the blockages uh is to think about um
the apprentice scheme think about the
kickstart scheme
through the eyes of small business
owners so our pubs are run by
independent operators uh and you know we
regularly look at these schemes and say
well why can we not get more traction
because they're overly bureaucratic and
they're complicated and we need to make
everything flow as simply and and
smoothly as possible uh and thinking
about each individual small business
having to undertake the the the workload
to make these schemes work which
everybody wants did you want to jump in
there just on on the apprentice topic
and this idea that apprenticeship is a
second class uh you know root into i'm
i'm slightly biased here i left school
at 16 and did an apprenticeship i don't
think i did too bad for myself the
process that followed so i think it
really is it's a great grounding and so
you know somebody was talking uh earlier
on about uh on the job training actually
on the job training is some of the best
training that we are actually able to
give our youngsters so these are not
negative things these are really
positive things and and you started as a
apprentice and you can go far beyond
that well i mean it's so important i i
qualified as a chartered accountant
and you qualify while you're working
i've worked with a firm called ui and
you know you on it's on the job training
and you get a professional qualification
i want to pick up on bob's point so
important
throughout this pandemic
it's my father remember said that the
true test of leadership is not
in the good times it's in times of
adversity and this is when business
leadership has been really tested and
how businesses have treated their
employees will be remembered will be
remembered by the employees the ones who
were treated badly the ones were treated
well and companies having a purpose is
so important
and a company with purpose will work
very closely with everybody with
the whole family that makes up the
employees the customers the suppliers
the advisors they're partners of the
same family if you have that attitude it
works and what is absolutely awful
is if you have bullying of any or any
sort going on
and to your point trade unions
there was a photograph taken on the
steps of number 11 with rishi sunak the
director general of cbi
and the head of the tuc
side by side government unions business
working together and we helped work the
furlough scheme so much through this
pandemic we've worked closely together
and that's how it should be
we've got a question from the audience
matt in the audience i think wants to
ask about
matt in the audience wants to ask about
incentives
oh it's nat sorry not matt not there you
are
um so we saw the data earlier on and it
was really interesting but i think that
we can all agree that education and
health should be considered as important
as our finance sectors and and we we
shouldn't really accept lower salaries
in this areas as a result of that so
surely recruitment retention and quality
could all be improved as a result of
increased investment in these areas but
not just from a training and
pre-employment perspective but following
on we need to keep people in these jobs
and then ultimately they act as role
models for the young people coming
through we don't have to spend as much
time trying to recruit at an early age
because we've got the role models later
on to encourage them to come through who
wants to take that client that sounds
like
one for you well i'd say the same is
true in hospitality actually so uh you
know our our challenge is to is to is to
keep people in development develop
their time and hospitality into a
long-term career
and we have to work harder as a sector i
i think in in achieving that because it
is a meritocracy and it's a you know
it's a flat structure and people can
move through it very fast so
i totally agree you know getting people
in an entry level and then enabling them
to grow and developing their skills on
the job and it is very much on the job
training um and you know
we have a good pathway to do that uh we
need to do it better
i think you're absolute spot on that um
lifelong learning is incredibly
important now it's not just about
entry level it's throughout because we
know the labor force that's coming
through is much more mobile if we're not
going to give them the experience if
we're not going to look after them we're
not going to
ensure that their well-being is priority
then they will leave and we'll be you
know the investment is gone um but the
point you're making around role models
is absolutely important um relatable
people who can support young people in
places like rotherham you know where
there is generations of worklessness
and say to them look we made it you can
make it this is the way we will support
you and invest and tell those young
people that you are important
is beyo i think that's a single thing
that will
um address some of the complexities in
our labor market mentoring is key
i think the the data that you shared at
the beginning demonstrate your factors
we've got role models in in tech and
these you know upcoming innovative
careers where individuals are valued as
employees and we've seen high vacancies
and not as much interest in some of the
other areas like hospitality and leisure
where we haven't got the same amount of
role models active that's right
well i think i think the point you're
making is
that teachers people in education
nurses
do they get paid for what they're really
worth
i believe they get way way underpaid
i mean do you remember the teachers who
changed your life
they they change our lives they make our
lives they save our lives you know so i
believe that we've got to really
encourage people to go into those
careers and you follow your passion not
your pension and what you really love
doing i mean solicitors now american
firms in the city are paying newly
qualified solicitors i heard yesterday
the extreme is 250 000 pounds
to somebody in their early 20s 125 000
pounds
that's the disparity that exists
yes i often wonder where i where i went
wrong really and obviously
but i mean we're all agreed that
education is very very important we've
got a budget coming up on the 27th of
this month we've had the institute for
fiscal studies yesterday their green
budget and they're making the point that
essentially spending on the nhs is
crowding out all other areas
of public spending those unprotected
areas of government local government
education defense transport all of those
are going to be squeezed all the money
is going to the nhs are you comfortable
with the way that
the nhs almost appears to be a cuckoo in
the nest and all other public spending
is being crowded out
historically if you look at overall um
public spending to gdp
we've tried to get to around 40
of of gdp
now if you look at the figures during
the pandemic i mean it's gone way over
that then you say that's in a time of
crisis then you say you need more
spending on health which we do then you
say you need more one of the things a
pandemic has really highlighted
is social care that it's been a
neglected sector i was shocked in april
last year went on a major television
program and the news broke that that day
but patients were being sent back from
hospitals into care homes without being
tested
i said how could this be happening and
then it highlighted how social care has
been neglected so it needs more funding
no question about that so how do we now
looking forward give the spending is
required but also increase the tax take
to be able to spend to spend it to pay
for it but also increase the growth
because if you have a an austerity
high tax
that will stifle growth that will stifle
domestic investment that will stifle
inward investment with the second
largest recipient of inward investment
in the world if you put up taxes too
much if just if your spending is out of
kill you will not attract that
investment so we've got to be very
careful going ahead there's no question
the investment is required
clive have you run the numbers how much
is this rise in national insurance next
year going to cost you
painful
but it's not but it's it's not just
national insurance it's it's the cost
increases we're seeing on virtually
every line of the p l so it's the
cumulative impact of that but in terms
of the government investment and where
the money goes i would encourage the
government to think of it as investment
and not as a cost so particularly you
know
obviously you know my world is embedded
in pubs and hospitality
we
by supporting our sector
that is supporting the regeneration of
jobs and local economies in
in hundreds of thousands of every town
and village actually across the uk we
are the you know we are a good conduit
to reinvesting in local communities
creating jobs investing capital into
uh into our buildings into new
businesses uh and investing in improving
our businesses and we're still at that
stage at this transition stage where you
know we we need that support to be able
to help to stimulate the government uh
the economy recovery and the leveling up
agenda uh we're you know a brilliant
route to achieve that
and all of the costs that you know we
are incurring at the minute are just
getting in the way of that
car you must be seeing that as well
absolutely i mean the the cost increases
have have been uh you know quite quite
brutal for for all for all sectors i
think it is a difficult challenge for
the government as to whether spend the
money i always think of it they've
they've got to spend it where they think
they're going to get the best value from
it you know and and so i think that
that's that has to be focused you know
you do things sector-wide you end up
spreading lots of money and i appreciate
is government it's very difficult to be
to be narrow but uh but i think if we
could be a little bit more intelligent
in our decision making and make sure
that that recognizing we have got to pay
down the debt that we've we've increased
you know in as a part of kovit that was
that's not a freebie somebody's got to
pay for that well we're never going to
pay down the debt
we'll eventually pay it down but uh um
you know we we
won't pay it down completely you're
right but but to pre-pandemic levels is
where we should be aiming for um however
i also do think you have to be very
careful that you know it's about growth
it really is about growth uh and where
and we need growth in all sectors not in
in one or other sector so this isn't
about just engineering or or just
hospitality or healthcare it's it's
everywhere and that's a really difficult
challenge to to balance and that's back
to this you know you you attract
investment by being productive
well i mean you as a business you're
going to be hit in a few years time by a
big jump in corporations absolutely are
you going to get value for money from
the government for that for all these
extra taxes that you're going to be
paying yeah great great question it's
very difficult to tie those taxes into
real real value for money so those are
coming i mean the only other thing i
would say is there are some positive
things that have been done the super
deduction which is a way to get large
businesses uh to invest in technology to
drive productivity and i think that's a
that was a great lever in last year's
budget but it's too short-term because
it actually that will fall out just as
the corporate uh
taxis have got corporation taxes going
up so i think there are things that the
the government could do rather than
hitting people with a stick but actually
giving them a carrot to invest can often
can often get the same if not a better
outcome just quickly to add to that it's
a very important point you made the
super deduction to encourage investment
government can do a lot to incentivize
that problem is that's going to be taken
away at the same time the corporation
tax is going up so our message governors
keep that in incentive going but we as a
country
under invest in research and development
and innovation we spend 1.7 percent of
gdp america germany is 2.8
israel 4
if we spend that extra 1 that's an extra
20 billion pounds a year if you imagine
the productivity increase the growth the
employment that's generated out of that
increased investment that's what we
should be investing absolutely and there
is some rumor that that that target for
for r d will actually push out we spend
more than those figures in r d but we
are a technology an engineering company
we have to invest i think again it's
it's when you're making those tough
decisions be careful not to to just look
at the here and now and do have one eye
to the long term and i know that's a
really difficult balance and we all do
that in our business life and the
government has to do it at the country
level but um fundamentally it's easy to
to have a short win it's easy to make
everybody happy now the goal is not
about everybody happy now it's about
that long-term journey
we have a question from phil miller in
the audience is phil here
good to see you sir
yeah my question is that obviously since
cobia and everything it's pretty tight
for money in businesses and obviously
we're looking to get to net zero what
are the chances of the government giving
a low cost
loan
to help the green infrastructure
thanks phil did everyone catch that who
wants to have a tackle at that of the
champion at the bitcoin i'll have a bit
of a go of it of it
and i think that well low-cost loans i
think what government first of all that
the challenge for decarbonisation for
this country is huge we you know we
people just don't get the scale of the
challenge in front of us we did a piece
of work to just look at the north west
and said if you were going to get that
to net zero by 2050 you're going to have
to invest 200 billion pounds okay that's
just one area of of the of the country
now on a positive note that 200 billion
is not necessarily have to be public
when in fact it shouldn't be
and the model we need to look at is is
offshore wind
where the government set long-term
policy it set some seed funding so it
did provide some incentive for people to
invest and that created a market that
then attracted huge amounts of
investment both both uk and
international investment and actually
then we saw the price of of offshore
energy drop so there's a really good
model so we know how to make
decarbonization work i would just caveat
with a couple of things and said uh i
think as a country we've done a lot so i
get the opportunity to speak to my
colleagues across the world and i do
think we are leading the the charge on
on decarbonisation we don't always get
it right but i think we're leading the
charge what we've done so far is about
fixing the big centralized uh stuff like
power generation i think the next things
around heat uh
homes buildings and transport are all
local topics and i think that is another
challenge and i know your panel this
afternoon is around leveling up but as a
lad from rochdale with most of our
facilities based in the north of england
i'm pretty pretty passionate about this
topic and i think there is a a role for
for the regions to take in in leveling
up and i've seen that in in some regions
like manchester and liverpool where
where they've
coordinated themselves and now the
government need to
to devolve more powers to those there
are some regions that are not quite so
well coordinated right so so there are
some regions that need to organize
themselves to get the benefit from it i
think if they are able to do that that
the transport challenge the heat
challenge their local challenges they
will generate local jobs for local
people at very good levels and actually
if we create markets there is more than
enough investment globally to actually
to do that the government need to create
stable policy and to provide a little
bit of seed funding to get the whole
thing started thanks scott wait it's
taken us 40 minutes but we finally have
the expression leveling up
bingo
someone
what do you understand by the term
leveling up is it just a bit of
empty rhetoric is there actually
something behind it i think it's
absolutely essential i think we need to
be in a position where every person in
this country has the opportunity to
access the opportunity
jobs that are available across the uk
so it needs to be more than just talk it
needs to be action i think we are in a
position now
to rethink and reset you know the
pandemic has provided us opportunities
to recalibrate and to think through
how do we actually make things happen
like leveling up how do we get
every young person in this country
into
jobs that are available
and there are many jobs are available
and to do that it cannot be the
situation now
that the only way young people get jobs
is through personal connections it has
to be open to every single person and
the way to do that is what we've been
talking about today is about ensuring
that business
gets into schools alongside education
and exposes these young people to work
becomes the trusted adult that
identifies career opportunities um
and actually i talk about young people
because that's my job but actually
there's a huge amount um to do with the
over 50s as well you know mentoring
should be
a sort of tool to enable um labor market
to become much more fluid um and i think
leveling up is essential really really
good point there about older workers i
mean
we keep being told by the government
that it's desirable for some people to
change careers mid-track but i mean do
you see it in your business clive do you
see people over the age of 50 saying
i've had a
you know
a damascene moment and i want to go and
pull pints
uh coming in to the industry at an older
age um
not so much um probably something we
should be trying to attract actually uh
we don't care how old people are or
where they come from we want them to
have a personality and a great work
ethic and a passion for hospitality
so
not particularly you know
our issue is you know is that we over
index on on younger workers which is
great
um we under index on older workers so
you know that's a good idea in a
campaign for uh people of my age and
older to come into hospitality if this
goes badly i might end up doing it again
i used to do those points on the red
line in whittington in manchester a
great man
look we talked we talked about
reskilling we talked about uh some of
the supply chain issues that you're
facing labor shortages the the elephant
in the room really is the economic
backdrop
potentially a rise in interest rates
around the table the money markets are
pricing him at least a couple by this
time next year
how much of a threat is that going to be
to this nascent recovery that we're
seeing
so just before i answer that if i may
just pick up a comment very important
point about this leveling up in albina
it's prosperity throughout all the
regions
and it should not be at the expense of
london it should be london prospering
benefits the whole country but it's
london and the rest of the country
and when it comes to climate change
heat is such a big issue that we we
don't address i chaired the heat
commission one third of greenhouse gas
emissions comes from heat
half of that comes from buildings and
out of the 29 homes in this town 29
million homes in this country only one
million are up to the standard way to
reach net zero by 2050 that means
upgrading 28 million homes the cost of
that the jobs that are created to skill
and implement that
the body that needs to be created we've
got the national center for
decarbonization of heat in the west
midlands that could do this throughout
the country it's a huge challenge and
we've got to face it we've got cop 26
the un climate change conference this is
where britain can show global leadership
on the stage well we're all about big
ideas and i think you've just come up
with a big idea for jobs there
and if i can just add you know what
gives me confidence that how we'll get
there and how it will be funded
i have no idea but what i do know is
that is that i have absolute
confidence and excitement about the
younger age group our consumer of
tomorrow or today will demand these
things so that they won't be coming into
our pubs if they don't meet you know the
the the criteria and you know and that
actually gives me the confidence
from an employee workforce point of view
they want to work for us our consumers
won't want to be coming in so these
changes absolutely um will come through
we have to find a way of
funding them uh effectively back to this
point of the interest rate so guys how
are you going to trade through this i
mean i think from from my perspective
the interest rate is perhaps not a
direct uh uh challenge but it impacts
markets and it impacts confidence and
anything that does that and perhaps uh
karen mentioned before just how
how fragile the recovery is and and i
will say it really is fragile it's it's
we're on the knife edge um or i'm ever
the optimist right i'm convinced we will
come out well but but i have to say that
any dints to to to
the confidence of of of public investing
on hospitality markets for example or
major investments in national
infrastructure anything that stops
people doing that and we may find
ourselves uh the the the the positive
you know it was mentioned uh the other
day that our recovery is the highest
performance of our
economy since the recovery of kovid is
the highest in g7 that's great that's a
great position but we need to keep it
there and anything that dense confidence
is is a worry to answer your question as
well
the chief executive
chief economist the i met in may when i
checked the b7 before the g7
she said you're going to have a great
recovery in this country you've invested
400 billion pounds to save your economy
you've got a vaccination program that's
world leading you'll have a v-shaped
back recovery what's happened since may
and now all these challenges got taxes
going up you've got the energy crisis
you've got the fuel crisis you've got
inflation now the inflation's meant to
be temporary but now there's talk that
this inflation which is meant to be four
and a half percent might go up to six
percent seven percent if that inflation
persists
the government will have the bank
willing to have no option but to put up
interest rates absolutely you put up
interest rates by one percent
the cost of government borrowing goes up
by 26 billion pounds mortgages go up
consumers suffer businesses suffer
investment is effective so this is a
very serious situation we've got to
watch it very carefully that's why i
keep saying to the government work with
business we've got to try and work
through this and generate that growth
generate the jobs so we can get through
this together and have a resilient
sustainable recovery i'm clive you're in
a consumer-facing business
next year april next year everyone in
this room possibly everyone on paye they
can have the experience of looking at
their salary notification and it will be
less than the month before that's a big
thing that hasn't happened to many
people in this country for decades it's
going to have a real impact on consumer
psychology isn't it yeah and people talk
about consumer confidence being
important in a recovery actually you
know we live in the here and now i think
you know pubs are a great litmus test
actually for the how the country has
performed that week
and the disposable income that people
have in their pockets a lot of that goes
on there you know leisure spend and and
for a lot of people in their community
pub uh so it's it's a very real threat
to us it's something that you know is
you know is very much in the here and
now not just for next
for for next march and april um and you
know we're absorbing cost left right and
center and so uh so our all our
businesses and our customers um you know
it's very real and that's why we need
the support to have a longer term
transition plan to prevent such a lumpy
recovery and to try and build a smooth
platform from from where we are now yeah
tough time for you guys really uh
i feel for you i really do
we're about to come uh to the conclusion
of this but uh we've had a lot of
interesting uh points made by panelists
and certainly one big idea from uh karen
villamori there for which many thanks
we're now going to hear a little from
our data and economics editor ed conway
about what he's going to be talking
about in just a few moments
hi ian uh and hello everyone um yeah i i
mean such an interesting panel so many
different issues that are kind of vine
with each other for our attention at the
moment and hopefully i'll be taking some
of those issues and trying to make a bit
of sense to them i mean often when it
comes to you know what we do in our
coverage we're trying to explain and
simplify what's happening right now but
it's hard to think of another time when
there's been so much complexity and so
many different dynamics happening
beneath the surface all of which we're
starting to notice now uh whether it's
us just kind of watching it or indeed
businesses and executives taking part in
it so we'll be going through some of
that we'll be looking through some of
the numbers i mean it's very difficult
for me to be in front of a big screen
like this without having a chart behind
me so we'll have lots of charts and lots
of data but also try to kind of
underline some of the points you've been
hearing about and some of the stuff
we'll be hearing about later on today
because we've got some other really
interesting guests uh yet to come in so
lots more interesting stuff yeah to come
ed what do you make of what you've
thought about the potential uh for an
interest rate right i mean i i
it's it's really interesting
the extent to which central banks you
know every time there's been an
inflation scare going back to the 1970s
or indeed before that
basically they have missed it you know
conventional economics has failed to
forecast inflation ahead of it actually
happening and if you look back at what
the bank of england was saying only
earlier on this year inflation was going
to go to maybe two percent it went way
above that it's gonna go to three
percent it went way above that as maybe
now they think it's going to go to four
percent so i mean if you read between
the lines you know they've they've been
behind the curve a lot you know
previously it's not impossible that they
might be behind the curve this time
around as well so it's not impossible no
you know markets aren't quite there yet
but you know there could even be one
this year we'll have to wait and see i'm
worth pointing out a lot of central
banks around the world were already
raising interest rates poland the other
day new zealand sri lanka i think the
russians have raised interest rates five
times this year so it's happening in
some parts of the world it's happening
and and you know when you look at
inflation it's clear that prices are
rising we're seeing this coming through
the pipeline right now i mean you know
i'm sure many in the audience and here
on the panel will have seen that as well
and just trying to work out i don't want
to give away all of what i'm talking
about later but trying to work out
what's coming down the path towards us
is i think going to be one of the
biggest challenges that you know we uh
within journalism but also within
business are going to face in the coming
years because you know this is uh going
to be a volatile world we're living in
at the moment
ed thanks for that quick word of thanks
to our panelists clive arvina karen
thank you all very much for your
contributions that is it from this
special ian king live part of the big
ideas live today here on sky news you
can follow ed's presentation next by
going to our live stream online and
we'll be back on sky news at 11 30 when
the former governor of the bank of
england mark carney will be speaking to
us about the challenges facing the world
and uk economies and the promise of cop
26 but that is it for now thank you very
much indeed
[Music]